do you think they're gonna try and lock
trump up no just like we he never locked
up hillary either unfortunately
i was i was thinking that that's that's
that's my main line of thinking nobody
prosecutes
it's not happening but the way i put it
but think about how insane they are
like maybe maybe joe biden joe biden
said he won't do it but i'm like i
always felt like the chance that trump
would actually lock up hillary was you
know
zero i knew it was zero two yeah but it
was funny it was a good meme right
yeah i kind of feel like the chan like
the probability that the left
tries to lock up trump is greater than
zero yeah maybe it's one percent maybe
it's two
they tried if you just try then i even
made they might you know
twenty percent when donald trump won and
then he was doing a rally he was like
no we're not gonna you know we're not
gonna lock her up that was you know that
was fun but it was only a big campaign
slogan of mine for
six months but yeah but his but but
trump's supporters were like you got it
trump we trust you whatever you say
yeah now joe biden wins and he's like
turn it on
pressure and so have you seen it can you
can either one of you say yeah he can
say it how do you
yes so he's gonna he's to mutter and
mumble
and the left is going to be screaming
and banging on walls and just like
shaking tables and vomiting all over
themselves demanding trump be arrested
there is going to be a section on the
left that still
the same people that didn't get over the
2016 election
they won't get over trump they're still
gonna screech about him
every time he tweets this is why i think
twitter actually won't ban him
right right right because they need
twitter people made careers as trump
reply guys
and like i know people who made money
it's crazy yeah but they they destroyed
their careers
well yeah you have no credibility left
yeah i knew i knew a guy who was
actually a producer for some big news
outlets yeah
and we were friends and then i saw him
just replying to trump saying really
dumb things
i messaged him and i was like yo dude
you gotta
stop doing this listen man like if you
want to tweet
talk smack about trump call him out be a
quote guy
right quote tweet and then say like
here's the source fact check but just
replying with these stupid hot takes
so cringe dude and he gained like a
hundred thousand followers
sure super excited who all abandoned him
oh absolutely yeah
the moment he stopped doing trump reply
hot takes and tried doing serious stuff
people started smack talking him
he started ignoring unfollowing and now
not only has he lost the reply guy grift
now he can't get hired anywhere because
they make fun of them like you're that
guy
he can't hire you are you not you have
no credibility yeah that was a funny
existence i always thought that like
replying directly to president trump was
a self-admit
admittance that you have tds like tds
one way or the other we talked about
like there are tds people that are like
super like trump can do no wrong that's
a that's gotta have a different name
there's still the right sycophant
syndrome yeah yeah yeah tss tss toxic
shock syndrome
i don't know oh yeah let's talk about
that i think sycophant
i think implies a higher level of
understanding what you're doing
okay so this is this is more like trunk
drone syndrome yes
yes zombies yeah trump drone syndrome
well there are them
and they exist but like i would see
people reply like every time i see
people that i follow who shall remain
unnamed
like replying directly to trump and i'm
like
you know like but but look look i think
it's fair to say
that there is a if you take all of
trump's voters
73 million there is a small fraction
maybe that's the second most votes
ever yes yeah right so most votes for
any sitting president
in an election yeah and it's the second
most for any candidate
so i think out of the 73 million you
maybe have a million that are
the trump drone like can do no wrong
he's always perfect he's always the best
but most of his voters are probably like
well you know
trump's got problems here and there
because i do these uh
you know like when i do videos and talk
about what's going on the ultra die-hard
trumpers are like they're really mad at
me
they're like posting memes and they're
making fun of me but i get dms from
people who are like yeah man i think
you're totally right
some some high profile and just like
regular one of the mil trump supporters
and they'll stray straight up like i
think you're right about what's going on
so here's the point
trump supporters mostly regular people
but
of the people who voted for biden i
would say the overwhelming majority are
trump derangement syndrome
well a good chunk of them and like union
guys straight blue
guys are there you know no i don't think
they voted for biden my dad did
wow my dad is a machinist a union guy in
wisconsin
yeah wow does he know anything about
biden no he doesn't know anything about
this
he's just blue trans pacific partnership
blue his job is going to be gone in a
week
he retired last year that's what he did
okay and he um
you know i don't i don't get political
with my family there's no point you have
literally nothing to gain
but like there are guys like him out
there yeah he's like yeah i just so i'm
like dad have you ever voted red
nope like really you voted for mitt
romney
um who ran against bush junior um
gore gore yeah you voted for al
gore for dukakis look he was born
in every every blue candidate since 1970
he's voted for it and like look it's
you know it's my dad whatever you know i
mean like i love him
but i mean people like that exist where
they're like punch that blue
blue vote the party and yeah that's true
blue no matter who yeah
well and one group of of blind voters
that
i think biden got that hillary lost
were disaffected bernie bros i think
yeah that disaffected bernie bros broke
for biden
more than they broke for hillary i think
when when biden got
when when bernie got screwed the first
time they just didn't vote
this time they're like okay we'll just
vote for how old are you
37 37 so we had uh vashon
and i think he's like 26 right 26 yeah
so during occupy wall street
when p when hundreds of thousands of
people took to the street to protest
barack obama for a variety of reasons
joe biden as vp vosh was 16.
and so he's here and he's arguing in
defense of joe biden
and i'm i'm like i'm i think i mentioned
this like i can't remember if it was
part of the conversation we talked like
four hours
and i said occupy wall street was a
protest organized against the federal
government in 2011
three years into barack obama's
presidency and joe biden
and they were talking about the bailouts
being bad in the big banks and they
opposed the wars and the drone bombs and
all that stuff
why would you vote these people back in
he was 16. he didn't know anything about
that
yeah i'm not going to be disrespectful
i'm saying quite literally you had
people
who were 10 years old yeah you're right
and now they're 20
and they're like yay 78 year old you
know neolib
bankster i think warmonger i think he
probably relates to joe biden because
they both like him young i think right
now but the uh yeah the um
yeah i think yeah well yeah it's funny
because
you know without getting a little too
off topic but it's funny that like
when you realize you're kind of old
i'm almost i'm closer to 40 than i'm 30
and i still
feel like i'm 20. you know except for
when i get up in the morning
then like then you know sometimes i have
to get up now in the middle of night to
pee
that's a new thing in the late 30s
i've been i've been skateboarding since
i was 13. and it's really weird cuz i'm
34 now and i still skate and i hear the
stories of people saying like man once
you get in your 30s i'm like dude i feel
literally the same
maybe it's because i'm part asian we got
that like we look there's something
there
yeah i don't know are you taking on are
you on that um did alex give you some of
those pills
what is that what is that stuff super
super male 1
i don't even like taking aspirins for
headaches i don't like to
drink water and you know maybe i eat too
much uh
uh combos well you eat that like a 16
year old since i've been here
no tip full exposed temple exposed
here's what i've seen i mean since i've
been here a handful of combos and a
fruit roll-up
yeah yeah what i just said
yeah i did eat that i ate that weird
healthy vegan pizza thing it wasn't bad
yeah
is that is that no not really i mean i
have breakfast i don't know i might put
eggs and bacon isn't it
oh okay what were you talking about
before you decided oh yeah
something got him off track boys yeah
being old and uh
young people not understanding what they
just voted for i can't i can't believe
i was just so surprised all these
progressives are like we have to vote
for joe biden
why what happened to progressives who
were 18 when i knew him they would never
have voted for an establishment democrat
yeah that's so that never would have
happened it's crazy to me that
that all these occupy people were split
in the middle between some of them
a bunch of them are trump supporters
that makes sense to me trump opposes
free trade agreements
trump was basically a bull crash in the
cathedral
these occupy style people who are
pro-biden and i'm like
i see them they weren't they weren't
pro-biden they were anybody but trump
yes
i think why well but here here's the
thing though i think
that what happened in 2020 was very
similar to what happened in 2016
that there were an absolute ton of
anybody but hillary's
yeah which is why trump won some of
those states that you know were like
wisconsin
margins you know people in wisconsin
weren't voting for hillary clinton right
that wasn't happening
um so when you get like your status quo
old white guy
then all of a sudden they're like oh
okay yeah joe biden's chance he's like
my only chance to actually win because
he's tried what like three times
he's so yeah yeah yeah but man you know
the media
they they they battered trump up for
years just getting anything they could
out of him
what's gonna happen that's why i'm
saying trump should go
totally dark i mean he has been for the
most part he basically has he's kind of
chilled out this week
he's chill out this way but they've got
all the lawsuits to report on
so imagine if imagine if joe biden's
inaugurated trump just
nothing he just fades off in obscurity
again
after declassifying area 51 files
because we need to know
we do but yeah i mean they would crumble
and it wouldn't
it wouldn't take long it wouldn't take
long no they would first first they
would write trump hasn't tweeted all day
something must be up
yeah the next day they'll write it's
been two days yeah then everyone will be
like
that then you'll get a theme where
they'll be like it's acceptable to write
about because everyone's asking
questions
and then it's like one week on where is
donald trump and they say we all know
he's the most racist and vile bigot
but now he's going dark is this part of
a secret plot trump's going to be
sitting on a beach sip sipping a pina
colada or whatever
diet coke yeah yeah yeah yeah well the
yeah well my part my thing is they're
still going to go after trump supporters
that's still going to be yeah they're
still going to go you know they're still
going to go after the
because you see it in hollywood some of
the worst vile garbage humans on the
planet in my opinion
saying you know like i'm still
disappointed that 71 million americans
are racist
73 million sorry like you got like cold
air up there then you get all these
then you get like these um uh cool bears
they're all dumb the the yeah
like they're so dumb they don't even do
anything well they totally do though
like okay allow me to i know this
probably isn't like this isn't going to
get you in trouble but
nothing grinds my gears more than these
brits or like foreigners coming over
here
and getting late night show hosts and
getting rich
dumping on america you got trevor noah
you got
uh james corden you got all these people
uh um john oliver oh i shed a tear i was
so powerful to be able to well he's an
american citizen now i'm pretty sure i
know he voted yeah but he made like a
big deal about i'm like dude
the only reason you're popular is
because you're just another vehicle to
deliver that mainline tds
that the far left audience needs we we
we have our pro trump brits and
canadians
you know we do paul joseph watsons and
piers morgan i think right yeah but he's
kind of in the middle
yeah he goes both ways yeah he was it's
it's really weird too but these guys
aren't hosting television shows
right piers is but but he's but he's
he's in the uk
and so if you're in the uk and you're
writing articles about trump that's fine
and to be fair paul just watson doing a
youtube show where he talks about
everything from modern art
culture to stuff like trump i think it's
fair as well
when you are not american and you come
here and host a show where you tell
americans what to think i'm kind of like
bro
you you don't know is trevor now
american no south africa
but he got american citizenship yeah of
course he
of course of course totally fine with it
i mean literally if they're not
if people who aren't citizens who are
commenting oh okay sure well i'm just
saying it grades
it grates me a little bit when a guy
comes from a country where like
um white farmers are being massacred
talking about how america's so bad
you know maybe you know talk about some
things that are bad
you know on both sides of the the aisle
you know these guys are so
partisan that you know look at at least
sean oliver was he was
uh jon stewart he was definitely left
but he would also
like he was it wasn't so bad he wasn't
so like lazy and like oh his hands are
small kind of jokes
yeah my issue is predominantly we have
we have uh it's not so much the late
night house necessarily
i'm not a fan of john oliver because i
think he's plastic and formulaious
yeah it's so like every single joke is
the same and it's kind of like uh-huh
and especially now that they're doing it
from home and there's no there's no fake
laugh track it's kind
it's actually it's like a horror movie
remember the first like month when they
ultimately i'll
try to do their show on youtube just
don't
know him was like trying to pause for a
laugh and there's just nothing and it's
like but i don't
what i don't understand is like trevor
noah does his show from like this weird
corner of his room or whatever yeah it's
like dude
like we i'm i'm in my house right now
look we've got paintings we've got like
we did
we did the walls up all nice with like
this vinyl you know
well these dudes have real money like
they have they have like
wealth let's fake authenticity like
we're at home with you
i'm just like you yeah look i haven't
cut my hair
but they still the crazy the crazy thing
is
like when you do your segments you don't
script anything do you no yeah
that's like the real political
commentary on youtube most of the the
bigger channels
or i should say the like political
commentary channels that are original
authentic
yeah not scripted yeah there's a couple
of like video essay guys out there
and guests that do a good job but most
most of it is pretty off the cuff
you know but then you look at samantha
bee and john oliver and trevor
i'd rather not no thanks yeah i'm good
yeah samantha bee is hard
she's the worst yeah if you see her
tweet uh the ap tweeted out tomorrow's
international men's day and she's like
oh
what a great day to stay inside because
men suck
she's just worried that's the thing
right it's like uh
you know right now i've always been you
know
middle of the road for the most part
during occupy wall street the left loved
me
yeah because i was like showing what was
going on and the cops were shoving
people and hitting people
and then you know i had a bunch of right
wingers always saying like f you yakipay
you blah blah
then when the trump stuff happened and
i'm like oh the media is lying about
this all these trump people are like oh
wow you know tim's are great in the left
is like tim's our graph
well isn't it isn't it funny how like
you can remain the same but who's in
power changes
yeah therefore the perceived allegiance
changes the funny the funny thing now is
i have trump supporters calling me a
grifter and i have leftists saying oh
tim's finally coming to his senses and
i'm like no no you're all
like the tribalism is dumb if it's true
and and i i'm just going to say what i
think but i said this is going to happen
i was like
if if if it goes bad for trump and i
start reporting on it
then i know the right's going to get mad
at me the reality though is
most moderates like the regular people
from occupy actually became trump
supporters and always have followed me
and then the moderate conservative types
who are seeing the same thing are dming
me saying like i think you're right
about what's going on and stuff like
that
it's just always the the hard like
antifa types in the far left are like
tim's a traitor and now the right is
like tim turner's back on trump
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time